so Donald Trump went on a pardoning
spree yesterday and there are all sorts
of different cakes and reports about
this what it means how he picked who to
pardon but unfortunately the most
precise and narrow analysis is that
Donald Trump is doing three things here
and they're all bad number one this is
an example of elites pardoning elites
plain and simple and this is the also
Donald Trump laying the groundwork for
future pardons of his own convicted
associates this is also number three an
indirect attack on James Comey and
Robert Muller and we're going to go
through each of these in order Donald
Trump yesterday pardoned people ranging
in skin color ranging in political party
and it is all very much a sham now
before we get into it remember that a
pardon is a form of clemency a pardon is
when a government official forgives a
certain criminal offense the offense can
stay on the person's criminal record the
person is not subject to further
restrictions or criminal penalties that
other convicts or ex-convicts may be
subjected to a pardon is a form of
clemency clemency is a general term for
reducing the penalty for a particular
crime without clearing the criminal
record it could be a pardon could be
that a sentence gets commuted could be a
reprieve which is you temporarily put
off or suspend the punishment but don't
cancel it altogether in total Donald
Trump granted 11 clemency instances
yesterday it includes Edward John
DeBartolo jr. a former real estate
developer an NFL executive pled guilty
to sexual assault charges Trump granting
him clemency rod Blagojevich the corrupt
Democratic governor of Illinois former
governor accused of trying to sell a
Senate seat has served eight years of a
14 year sentence for those pay-to-play
charges Trump is getting him out of
prison former New York police
commissioner Bernie Kerik convicted of
tax fraud and lying to officials a
Republican Bernie Kerik of course also
connected to Donald Trump's personal
attorney Rudy Giuliani Mike Milken
an investment banker known as the junk
bond
convicted of felony charges that
included conspiracy securities fraud
kind of the poster child of 1980s
financial scandals and Donald Trump has
also pardoned former Bush administration
official David Safa vien who was convict
convicted in connection with the
Abramoff Jack Abramoff corruption
scandal so a lot of corruption here
being pardoned Donald Trump said about
rod Blagojevich it was a persik a
prosecution by the same people Comey
Fitzpatrick the same group Trump said
misstating by the way the Illinois US
Attorney's last name so first of all
there was this reaction of oh wow Trump
hardened a Democrat Rod Blagojevich
remember this was the pardon of Liguria
[ __ ] was a way to attack James Comey it
was elites pardoning elites more than
anything else
it was also Trump pardoning corruption
and corruption continuing to be
normalized which is one of the themes of
these clemency grants and then you also
saw you know Trump pardoning some white
people and some black people it's
irrelevant we are again talking about
elites here and what this functions as
is a pretext for future pardons of Trump
associates to be able to say when Trump
ultimately pardons stone Michael Flint
you know we don't know who yet Trump
will be able to say listen I've been
doing this all along I find people who
were railroaded and I pardon them it
includes people of all skin colors it
includes members of multiple political
parties that's all this is it is a lot
of corruption related charges being
pardoned Trump arguably the most corrupt
president in the modern era it's a sham
and I would be shocked if at minimum
Trump doesn't end up pardoning Roger
stone no matter what sentence Roger
stone ultimately gets and it may be much
shorter than what was initially
recommended by prosecutors as you know I
don't know if Trump will ultimately
parter pardoned his former national
security adviser Michael Flynn Michael
Cohen from old personal lawyer I think
is less likely for a pardon after what
has been said publicly between the two
but this is a message from Donald Trump
if you do things I don't like to Roger
stone and Michael Flynn or whoever I
will just pardon them and he will this
is also the forced normalization of not
just political corruption but also of
other crimes and you are going to hear
you know Blagojevich got a raw deal
political corruption that's not really a
crime you will hear I've pardoned
Democrats and Republicans alike and of
course you have to step back and see the
bigger narrative this is elites
protecting elites this is the rich
protecting the rich and it is all a
shell game and with rod Blagojevich
as the specific example and I want to
talk about this next this also appears
to be very much related to some
appearances that Rod Blagojevich's wife
had on TV bad-mouthing the people that
were investigating Donald Trump let's
talk about that next do you feel like
you just don't have enough time to
become as intellectually well-rounded as
you would like to be that they're just
not enough hours in your week for you to
read all of the books that you want to
read one of our sponsors is called
blinka stand it's an app that lets you
consume an entire nonfiction book in 15
minutes it's only about eight bucks a
month but you can try it for free for a
week and get 25% off a subscription
when you go to blankest comm slash
Pakman what blinka studs is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and condense them into either text or
audio that you can read or listen to in
just 15 minutes and what you get is all
of the most important ideas and
information from the book imagine being
able to listen to an entire nonfiction
book in the amount of time it takes you
to drive or walk home from work I just
finished listening to the way we eat now
by bee Wilson whose work I've
recommended to you before super
interesting look at how the global food
system works and impacts the way that we
live blink is has totally transformed
how I consume information I love it of
course I read a book in its entirety
when I can but there are simply just so
many books that I want to read and would
not
have the time for if it weren't for
blankets they have books on politics
economics philosophy science you name it
you can try it out yourself totally free
for a week and get 25% off if you decide
to subscribe just by going to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video like the
rest of us I bet you're going into 2020
thinking about what you didn't get
around to in 2019 and your goals for the
new year if you want to work towards
being your best self in 2020 understand
more about the world around you and make
sure that your time is well spent then
blink astiz for you